- [Voiceover] This salad sucks.
In fact, most salads suck.
Most salads suck because
people don't know how
to make salads.
So here's how to make a
salad that doesn't suck.
First thing, don't use iceberg lettuce,
or any lettuce,
unless you really want your salad
to taste like a glass of water.
Use a variety of other greens
to get a better texture
and flavor, like spinach,
kale, arugula, basil,
and cilantro.
Yes, you can add herbs to your salad,
and it's amazing.
Second, chop everything very fine.
The more you can fit on your fork,
the better it will taste in your mouth,
and here's an extra tip.
A little finely chopped cabbage
makes a world of difference.
Third, you'll never get
full just eating leaves.
So add substance,
like chicken, broccoli, avocado,
berries, tomatoes, tortilla
chips, seeds, and nuts.
These things will make
your salad more filling
and more delicious,
and therefore suck less.
The last step is to add dressing,
but not too much!
You'd be surprised how
far a tablespoon will go
if you toss it enough.
Now that's a salad that doesn't suck!
(funky jazz music)